hey guys it is the ninth of July my name
is Jessa McDonald and you're watching
games Kourtney's a fairly sizable 2.2
gigabyte patch has landed on steam for
the witcher 3 and if you find yourself
wondering what on earth could be taking
up that much space i'm here to tell you
developers that a project have said that
the update adds more language options
for the game's art book manuals and maps
as well as some additional wallpapers
reddit user madness 795 discovered that
this content is totally optional so if
you're short on hard drive space you can
delete the artbook map and manual
subfolders from your games directory and
not affect your game should you decide
you want it at a later point just verify
your game cache through steam and you
can redownload it former sony online
entertainment exactly on smedley has
told lizard squad hacker julius kev
amake quote i'm coming for you after his
prison free ruling the hacking group
took responsibility for placing a bomb
threat which grounded a plane smedley
was on in 2014 and smedley claimed
killer mark ii personally harassed him
and licked his personal information
smedley took to twitter where he calls
the 17 year old hacker a dirtbag and
adds quote his parents need to be held
accountable for his actions in addition
to his goalie to jail he's also said he
might take the family to civil court in
response to the suspended sentence
verdict which is capped give amake from
going to jail the teenager tweeted out
MC Hammer's you can't touch this so yeah
dirtbag does seem to be the right word
finally we have some details on Halo 5s
new war zone map from comic-con
microsoft announced the map entitled
radon apex 7 at comic-con and it's the
biggest war zone map ever microsoft
revealed the 12v 12 map through an 80
9500 block mega bloks model and yes u
100% her that right the model weighs
half a ton and took two builders 16
weeks to create it also has sweet LED
lights as for the actual map microsoft
have said is a spiritual successor
the halo combat evolved mission a silent
cartographer you'll need to fight the
Covenant control the forerunner spire in
the center of the island and use a
system of caves or a beach approach to
flank the base should you lose the spire
halo 5 releases on October 27 for Xbox
one lunar down in the comments what you
think of the new war zone map and if
you'll be picking up halo 5 you can head
to gamespot always got news on a cod
mini fridge and then users there'll be
no multiplayer in horizon zero dawn that
is everything I have for you today as
always let me know what mattered to you
and Rob we'll be bringing you tomorrow's
news from the US so I can go home and
continue being ill he's awesome you'll
love it assuming i don't have the
t-virus or anything like that I will
catch you again on Monday